is there something
that
you find
fascinating interesting
beautiful
ugly
surprising about sperm
i think sperm is um yes it is a very
interesting bodily fluid maybe i'll
write about it in a second or third book
we'll see but uh
you know i guess sperm is interesting
because it's kind of the only projectile
bodily fluid um from the body
um you know
vomit can be projectile usually that's a
disease state that's not the expected
kind of normal healthy state oh sneezing
would you classify that or no true i
guess there's it's yeah there's some
particles in the air i guess it's not a
fluid i mean not a liquid um
but true i mean cough in addition to
sneeze right sneeze is how our nose gets
rid of something that shouldn't be there
cough is how our lungs get rid of
something that shouldn't be there
vomiting is sometimes how our stomachs
get rid of something that shouldn't be
there
all projectile sometimes in their own
way
sperm is sort of interesting it's
created with the food for its journey
sperm mostly feed off of fructose the
kind of sugar um you know for the few
days that they live inside the female
genital tract but it's sort of i like
comparing our genitals to the genitals
of the plant world which is flowers and
in the same way that uh
you know a touch me not uh for instance
the kind of flower where when you brush
up against it it sort of launches seeds
into the distance to try to
survive in a way kind of the sperm is
doing something similar launched into
the female genital tract and then all
trying to find this uh competing against
each other to find this egg it's really
amazing and when you learn about it from
the biological perspective
the most amazing thing is how many
things can go wrong um you know just in
the sperm not surviving long enough for
it making it to the egg and then some
genetic
abnormality causing a miscarriage it's
sort of astounding
that it works as often as it does and i
think the lesson there is just that
people have a lot of sex and so
statistics just favor it's going to work
out a good number of times
yeah and there might be intelligence in
the design of just the sheer number of
sperm maybe that's yet another way to
inject variety into the system
and redundancy i guess you know we have
two kidneys we have two hands if we lose
one we can still go on we have
you know however many millions of sperm
get sort of launched in every
ejaculation is uh you know if a bunch
fail
or don't make it inside there's papers
on this by the way uh that i read for
some reason not read but skimmed
for some reason which is uh
talking about which sperm usually wins
like what are the characteristics of
sperms that are winning and it's not the
fastest
it says
apparently there's some kind of
slaughter that happens early on people
will correct me but it's not the fastest
it's there's a aspect of it's the
luckiest it really is like the body
tries to make it a random selection
it tries to make it fair in making it as
random as possible
interesting and also interesting that
they're fueled by fructose they didn't
really think about that so they're a um
they're uh
carb-loaded athlete
right with food for the journey food for
the journey because i'm somebody that
actually does a lot of running
on um
i guess you would call me a fat adapted
athlete so i do
sort of meat
heavy diet and so you could do a lot of
endurance kind of stuff
when you don't need any carbs any
glucose any of that kind of stuff and
you're very low it's interesting to
think that sperm are like nope
they're total bros let's go to the gym
uh sprint
performance short term performance is
everything
you